those shows Daily Show and Colbert I
feel like are just bound for like
legendary status I mean if they're not
already I like I'm just always blown
away by stuff like that because it's so
hard to say something relevant or
something serious or more importantly
I'd like to say something critical but
to do it in a funny way I mean like the
fact that Colbert can do that night
after night and like really you know go
after the the sort of the you
know aspect of politics and really sort
of like you know he's doing a character
which is really funny and but at first
like a lot of Republicans didn't get
there like oh this guy's awesome and
this guy's talking to me I love this guy
and then I think after that thing where
he did the toast at the AP news thing I
think you were like oh wait is this guy
one of us but but you know they didn't
catch on to it for a while but um yeah I
mean I feel like both our shows daily
show the fact that they are you know I
think they're crazy statistics that like
more people get there or more young
people get their news and information
like from The Daily Show than any other
news source I mean it's insane but
awesome you know because they're getting
like current relevant information but in
a hilarious way you know yeah this I I
feel like those shows are just doing
something that's so hard to do and they
do it so well
it always killed me no I think like what
what the Daily Show does and what
Colbert does is completely justifiable
in the news world because first and
foremost it's supposed to be a comedy
show it's not supposed to be a news show
I mean yeah there is there are real
stories that are presented or you know
bullet points of actual facts that are
going on but that's supposed to be more
than anything a comedy show what's
retarded to me is what's going on on
like CNN where you watch that and it's
like and they're trying to be funny now
like they're doing shows that are kind
of funny and and you know in in their
reporting it's more about like
celebrities and entertainment and
like that then what where is their real
news like they're literally in our
country there isn't any real news
anymore like there's not you know the
the nightly news at 6 o'clock or 6:30
that's for old people I mean that's to
sell advertising time for sleeping pills
and adult diapers and stuff like that
you know it let me look at those
commercials so I feel like those stories
are geared towards that but like other
than like front line and like 60 minutes
you know CNN is a joke it's a joke you
know you really have to watch like BBC
to know like if you watch BBC news it's
like oh here's where the news is this is
real news and it's totally solid and
it's coming from another country we
don't do that like we can't for some
reason do that it doesn't sell
commercials